yesterday's White House press briefing
managed well first of all it was managed
not by press secretary Sarah Huckabee
Sanders but by her deputy the deputy
press secretary Raj Shah and it got off
to a very very fast start because after
the endless lies and the lies about
firings and hirings and the lies about
so much Associated Press reporter Zeke
Miller straight up said to rush as soon
as he turned it over for questions after
a couple minute comment why should we
believe anything that you tell us at
this point which is really a pretty
obvious question at this point seen as
very controversial and aggressive but
it's just sort of an obvious question
let's watch and most of what I'm most
interested in is the just laughable
response from Raj Shah here Zeke on
Thursday White House officials run out
of this stage and they said the
president would sign behind me this
legislation on Friday morning he
threatened to veto it awfully excited
ten days ago Sarah said that a charged
ambassador had to present confident
support would be leaving last Thursday
yeah it was advance that he would be
leaving the White House in about two and
a half weeks ago the president expressed
confidence in his attorneys and then
there's a bit of a shake-up there last
week so can you talk to speak to the
White House the credibility why should
we in this room and more important of
the American people trust anything this
administration's telling them well you
know our job is a press office and as an
administration is to give you the best
information that we have available to us
most accurate information in a timely
fashion
sometimes the dynamics are fluid in any
given situation you mentioned some
personnel matters facts and
circumstances changed we continue to
give you guys the best information that
we can as quickly as possible so good
for Zeke Miller right this is a good
question this is the type of question
that should be asked but the next step
if you've got to press them right Raj
Shahs answer is bogus unless the White
House press team is genuinely kept in
the dark about what is going on which is
possible in the Trump administration
anything is possible but it's sort of
hard to believe to say that they give
the most accurate information they have
at the time is obviously not believable
the White House press office hasn't been
in this level of disarray and disrepair
I would argue ever and it goes back to
the first day of this administration and
Sean Spicer who has done more to
embarrass and discredit the office of
the press secretary than any previous
press secretary and it started with his
day one pronouncement I call it the
belligerent pronouncement the coerced
pronouncement we now know by Donald
Trump that Donald Trump had the biggest
inauguration in the history of the
United States period end of story
Spicer started his tenure as White House
press secretary lying about the weather
on inauguration day something that
hundreds of thousands of people
personally experienced and millions more
watched on television and I also want to
point out that not just the lying but
the admitting to lying isn't that rare
in the administration we know that they
like Donald Trump recently admitted as I
covered that he lied to foreign leaders
including specifically Canadian Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau we covered it
when it happened Trump just making up
assertions out of thin air about trade
with Canada just made it up
hope Hicks Trump's former I guess like
her sixth or seventh who knows White
House communications director she
testified a few weeks ago that sometimes
she would lie to the press for president
Donald Trump
Kellyanne Conway concocting the
bowling-green Massacre to justify who
knows what depraved policy of Donald
Trump's that he was pushing at the time
some kind of wall or ban or travel ban
or whatever it was this is what they do
right so the answer to Zeke Miller's
question here is there is no reason why
anybody should trust any of these people
they should not be trusted and even
Trump came up once with the bogus live
just a demonstrable factual lie that he
had the biggest electoral victory in
history he was straight-up called out by
a reporter in person and just listen
Trump expressed no remorse he said I
well that's what somebody told me I
guess it was the biggest electoral
college win since Ronald Reagan
since Ronald Reagan with 300 or 306
electoral votes in fact President Obama
got 365 well I'm talking about
Republican President Obama 331 George HW
Bush 426 when he won as president so why
should Americans trust well no I was
told I was given that information I
don't I was just given we had a very
very big margin I guess I questioned why
should Americans trust you when you look
used the information they receive of
being fake when you're providing
information well I don't know I was
given that information actually I've
seen that information around yeah I was
thinking a lot of people aren't familiar
with that one but it's it's bad there is
only one way in which what Raj said is
true Shaw said that the press office
provides the most accurate information
at the time it's possible they have no
clue what's going on right they the
press office may genuinely have no
reason to think that HR McMaster and Rex
Tillerson are about to be fired even
almost as they are being fired because
they're not being told that it's going
on and that's the one other
interpretation of this and I don't know
whether that's true that would signal a
whole host of other problems going on
within the White House my baby maybe
it's something that we will someday
learn about but hey I wish there were
more follow-up but good for Zeke Miller
for asking the question we can only hope
there's more of this coming from the
press corps I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
show is on twitter at david pakman show
a quick break back after this normally
White House press secretaries know how
to lie in ways that are plausibly
deniable or open to interpretation White
House press secretary Sarah Huckabee
Sanders is now just concocting lies
whole cloth out of thin air you might
remember that yesterday we talked about
the census the 2020 census and I told
you that Wilbur Ross Secretary of
Commerce and his Commerce Department
announced that they are going to bring
back questions about citizenship in the
2020 census and I explained to you
yesterday this is going to hold down the
response rates of minorities they will
be undercounted this will have the net
result of shifting money away from some
of the large blue states with high
immigrant populations like California
and New York State it's gonna play
directly into the hands of Republican
gerrymandering and I also told you that
citizenship questions have not been on
the census since 1950 Sarah Huckabee
Sanders was asked yesterday about this
and she came up with the really specific
lie a totally demonstrable falsehood
that the citizenship question has been
on every census since 1965 other than
2010 what how did she come up with that
we have absolutely no idea here's the
video look this is a question that's
been included in every census since 1965
with the exception of 2010 when it was
removed this is we've contained this
question that's provided data that's
necessary for the Department of Justice
to protect voters and specifically to
help us better comply with the Voting
Rights Act which is something that is
important than a part of this process
and again this is something that has
been part of the census for decades and
something that the Department of
Commerce felt strongly needed to be
included again what is the point of
these briefings when it's just lies and
no real answers to the questions right
that this is transparently patently
absurd Lee false and now that sort of
that that's the big lie right the big
lie is no this has not been on every
census since 1965 other than 2010 this
has not been in the census at all since
1950 that was the big lie there is also
a smaller lie she even though that was
only like a 30-second answer she
actually told two major lies in that one
answer she also said something about the
reason we put that back in is that the
Commerce Department wanted to protect
voters and comply with the Voting Rights
Act that's also made up out of thin air
this is all based on a letter from the
DOJ headed by Jeff Sessions remember
asking that the census add the
citizenship question back in
on the basis of a recommendation from
John Gore John Gore was appointed by
Donald Trump and is best known for
Republican gerrymandering around the
country and that's the point of this
question being added to the census
earlier this week the first question to
the deputy press secretary was why
should we believe anything that you tell
us and I think that the first question
at every subsequent press briefing
should be Sara at the last press
briefing you told us x y&z all of which
were lies will you be telling lies today
and are you willing to clarify those
three lies from the last press briefing
that is how every single one of these
press briefings should be handled and I
hope that today someone says to her Sara
yesterday you said that the citizenship
question has been on every census in 65
other than 20 other than 2010 that
wasn't true can you tell us where you
got that information I hope that they
will ask her that today yeah see about
that there's also some low-hanging fruit
here which is that there was no census
in 1965 the source occurs every 10 years
in the years ending in a 0 like 2012 and
2020 and that was another survey but it
wasn't the census and we're sure that
there wasn't for some reason essentially
every year since 1790 every 10 3 10
years yeah listen that that is like a
tertiary lie at this point where it's
it's barely even registering and I don't
know if the unhinge degree to which
she's still telling these demonstrable
lies is because she sort of gets a kick
out of it I've said it it sort of looks
like she really likes bullying the press
corps and just I apologize for what
might seem as an unsavory comment but
sort of like throwing her weight around
not literally but figuratively or does
she feel like she's being bullied into
telling these lies by Trump or by
someone else I don't know but I'm
starting to get emails from people who
say they feel bad for Sarah Huckabee
Sanders I don't feel bad at all
she deserves to have her political
career destroyed for agreeing to
participate in this no one forced her to
take this job hopefully Sean Spicer's
career is over remains to be seen he may
just be on a sort of political break
until he does his next thing
but III understand how we might all feel
like some of these people are victims of
Donald Trump but she's one of the
perpetrators she may not be the top
perpetrator the perpetrator in chief but
she is a perpetrator here and I don't
feel bad for her whatsoever I think she
could be on her way out too I remember
in the last days of Sean Spicer we saw
less and less of him and more of Sarah
Huckabee Sanders yeah now it looks like
we're seeing more of Raj Shah than you
yeah I perhaps who I also think is an
absolute disaster and would bring a
whole new series of comedic press
briefings but yeah I think that she is
Trump has had at least two instances
major instances over the last month
where he's not been at all happy with
Sarah Huckabee Sanders and we'll see how
long her tenure is as White House press
secretary just making stuff up out of
thin air discuss this with us on our
subreddit at david pakman.com slash re d
di t next medical professor donald light
will join me to talk about
pharmaceutical industry myths looking
forward to that so Reuters is reporting
some potentially a pretty major news we
learned that North Korean leader Kim
jong-un went to China Sunday was there
until today earlier today they're there
12 13 hours ahead of us on a non
official visit and a picture of the two
leaders the chinese president g and kim
jeong-hoon from north korea has been
tweeted by a Chinese news agency Xinhua
news and this was reported originally
all by Chinese news and has since been
confirmed and as far as is known this is
the first time that Kim jong-un has left
North Korea since he took over power
about seven years ago in 2011 and
according to China while in China
President ji and North Korean leader Kim
jong-un have negotiated a pledge from
North Korea to denuclearize the Korean
Peninsula and you will soon see why that
language denuclearize the Korean
Peninsula
not just denuclearize North Korea
riah is very very relevant language for
what maybe in Kim Jong Un's mind here
that goes well beyond just being
semantics and this reportedly took place
during a meeting between the leaders of
the two countries and the immediate
reaction was this this must all be BS
but case in point Kim jong-un has not
left North Korea since taking power so
it's all unprecedented the fact that it
sounds hard to believe really shouldn't
tell us too much because we already know
that the trip in and of itself is sort
of historic at least in the context of
Kim Jong Un's reign in North Korea and
there is plenty of reason to be
skeptical right there's plenty of reason
to believe that Kim jong-un is thinking
of what we think of when we hear about
denuclearizing in the region but the
fact that this might be a thing is more
than enough reason to talk about it and
take it seriously
the real caveat here and I alluded to
this a couple minutes ago is that Kim
Jong hoon more than likely agreed to
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
in theory if all American troops leave
South Korea which just is not likely to
happen right this is potentially setting
up the United States to be blamed by Kim
jong-un for impeding denuclearization
because Kim jong-un now by saying hey
I'm I'm open to denuclearizing the
peninsula which includes two countries
North and South Korea what does that
mean in terms of how we should interpret
it well the United States military being
the military of a nuclear nation has a
saw a strong presence in South Korea so
what Kim jong-un I believe is
effectively saying here is I'm willing
to denuclearize North Korea if South
Korea is willing to denuclearize in the
sense of getting all military from
nuclear nations out of there meaning
United States troops have to go and it
just seems very difficult to think that
that's going to happen and in fact it's
very likely that this is an attempt not
not a stupid one by the way by Kim
jong-un to take the high ground pull
while he can because there's this window
here where it appears as though we are
going in the direction of talks that
will involve North and South Korea and
the United States potentially at the end
of May of this year just a couple of
months from now there's this window
right now where Kim can take the
political high ground and say I'm ready
to come to the table which by the way
he's always been willing to do he's
always been desperate to get to the same
table as an American president and I'm
willing conceptually in theory to agree
to denuclearize the peninsula which
would more than likely require the
United States to go they meet South
Korea and the u.s. and North Korea and
North Korea says hey we want peace and
stability let's have all nuclear powers
leave the peninsula we will denuclearize
in US troops must leave Trump overreacts
says no and then who knows what happens
and in the interim of course Donald
Trump completely predictably on Twitter
pushing this as sort of a victory
something unique that he has been able
to achieve tweeting this morning for
years and through many administrations
everyone said that peace and the
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
was not even a small possibility now
there is a good chance that Kim jong-un
will do what is right for his people and
for Humanity look forward to our meeting
and this is just the narrative is so
attractive to Trump he's so obsessed
with the idea as the sole and unique
Broker of progress in the region that he
if he even understands it is ignoring it
but more than likely doesn't know nor
care to understand that when Kim talks
about the denuclearization of the
peninsula he's talking about Trump
pulling troops and he likes the
narrative Trump does of hey I was
elected all of a sudden Kim jong-un
might do what is right it is more than
likely that Kim jong-un is at least on
the path of playing Donald Trump here
and of course Trump's not just not
knowledgeable enough to understand what
it is that Kim jong-un means by the
denuclearization of the peninsula
yeah presidents always take and receive
credit for favorable world events even
if they had little to nothing to do with
it
right and but I think if you if there
was an exchange where Trump is obnoxious
but North Korea decides to denuclearize
and it turns out the whole peninsula
decides the new denuclearize that's good
for us I think in the end uh I mean I
guess I don't know it's just that that
would include Trump saying yeah we'll
pull all of our troops more than likely
and and that's just not gonna happen
last night I decided to turn on the TV
for a few minutes I basically don't
watch news shows or political shows I've
talked about this before I've always got
like some Netflix shows that I'm
watching and yesterday I watched what
did I watch I watched an episode of
hostages great Israeli show finished
watching that an episode of that with my
girlfriend and I said let's just see
what's happening in the news right like
what's happening on Fox News what's
happening on MSNBC what's happening on
CNN I turn to CNN which by and large has
been doing a mix of good reporting on
the Trump administration combined with
some salacious stuff that's less
relevant certainly a much better option
than Fox News for sure and I see
Anderson Cooper who recently interviewed
stormy Daniels on 60 minutes sitting at
his news desk with legal analyst Jeffrey
Toobin Michael avenatti who's the lawyer
for adult film actress stormy Daniels as
well as the lawyer for Trump's lawyer so
Trump has a lawyer Michael Cohen Michael
Cohen is in such hot water now as a
result of the stormy Daniels thing and
the non-disclosures that he has retained
a lawyer named David Schwartz as I told
you before
Trump's lawyer has not lawyer DUP here
because of the trouble that that he
believes Trump is in he's lawyered up
because he potentially is in trouble
tells us how bad things are going this
was one of the most embarrassing and
pointless nearly half-hour segments that
I have ever seen on corporate media to
lawyers yelling at each other the way
they might do 30 seconds before turning
to fisticuffs in a bar right Michael
Cohen's lawyer David Schwartz is on the
most fundamental level a complete and
total embarrassment his mere presence on
the network is shameful stormy Daniels
attorney Michael avenatti he's known as
this really savvy legal operator
he completely embarrassed himself with
his behavior stooping to the same level
as David Schwartz making fun of
Schwartz's weight at one point how does
it count as sort of legal exploration of
the merits of a case to ridicule the
fact that the other lawyer is heavy
right I mean that it is absolute in
total embarrassment and I guess Anderson
Cooper and Jeffrey Toobin did what they
could to kind of control the situation
but CNN should certainly be embarrassed
about this as well I'm gonna play only a
few clips for you here it's just some
random stuff it's all like this nearly a
half hours worth take a look what's the
first thing that you think of I got to
go to my Pilates class that's the very
first thing that I think of when someone
comes up to me and threatens me with my
daughter anyone who has a daughter knows
you go right to the police it's
completely I'm sure she didn't go to the
police because she was scared and she
walked into the right that's where you
go to to get to the notion that he's
saying that it's defamatory power
lawsuit look so wait a minute last time
you didn't let me talk this time I'm
like well this time you are gonna let me
talk otherwise we're gonna have to get
the defibrillator out for you and I'm
concerned please go for right yeah the
American people saw last night I think
that's also kind of a fat joke right
like is it cuz the guy so heavy that if
he keeps talking he might need to be
defibrillated at her I don't even know a
half hour of this stuff here's just
another random sampling from later on in
the program she sat in an interview for
two hours or there abouts and she faced
the tough questions and she answered him
and the American people saw those
answers saw how she answered the
questions and I think 90% of America 90%
are you saying that it was Michael Kohn
who was at in Las Vegas by the Pilates
place are you saying it was him
personally course it wasn't Mike okay
you said that all sources saying that I
didn't think you know why God gave you
two ears and one mouth what about you
know it's like the tercel listen what
about your phone is
was the galaxy space of legal arguments
being made right aye these are two
lawyers I would hire right away and it's
very easy to say it's one person
instigating here these are attorneys
representing people who couldn't be more
in the public eye and they go on
national media and this is how they can
port themselves on national television
here's just another few seconds of this
nonsense to talk about the mauler to
talk about the some some fantasy
criminal indictment you don't know what
you have no idea what you're talking
about
interrupting you laughing with my body
just beat them alright can I speak you
know exactly what I can I can I just
raise just one more clip here and this
is sort of the epitome of the entire
thing let's talk about Michael Cohen
what kind of man this is this is the
kind of guy who claimed in connection
with that story that there's no such
thing as spousal rape this is a legal
genius right right completely false the
guy doesn't even know the law he's a
thug your friend is a million dollars
you see by the ways I thought he was you
did your lie detector test so okay no
galvanic skin response this is an utter
embarrassment as far as the substance
the only substance came from really
specific questions from CNN legal
analyst Jeffrey Toobin and it exposed
that Cohen's attorney really doesn't
have good answers to a whole host of
questions but it doesn't matter because
the entire thing was just an
embarrassment who at CNN thinks this is
a good idea how is it responsible
counsel and forget about Schwartz right
Schwartz is there merely to muddle the
water that's all he wants to do because
Michael Cohen is not in a good position
but stormy Daniels and her attorney
presumably are there to make her seem
more credible to explain the legal
underpinnings of what's going on here
what is the upside for avenatti to
appear in a setting like this and to be
completely unable to control himself it
is pathetic and embarrassing
every step of the way and this is where
I go off a to to the point where I say
is this just all we can expect from a
network like this because they've done
some good stuff yeah should Anderson
Cooper have done a better job at
facilitating that debate or did he just
let it go because it's good television
after all is it though I mean the thing
is I don't know that it is actually good
because when you've got four people
talking at once it almost doesn't matter
who it is or what they're saying it just
doesn't work and I get to my bottom line
on this story which is I think that this
is a legitimate story not because Trump
had sex with someone but because the
payoff might have been illegal because
of the concerning pattern of lies and
manipulation of women all of that stuff
but we're not dealing with any of the
real substance when it's for people
talking over each other for a half hour
and acting literally like school
children one of the worst moments I've
seen on CNN in a very very long time
this is one of the more complicated
stories where there are lots of little
details and it can become kind of
difficult to keep it straight but I want
to try because it's a really important
story and the wide angle on this is that
we've now learned that the hacker gusoff
er 2.0 was a Russian intelligence
officer now why do we care about gusoff
or 2.0 the reason we care is that gusoff
er 2.0 was considered to be the person
or maybe a group of people that hack the
DNC that's the hack that led to the
infamous leaks that were at the center
of an endless election controversy that
it seemed as though the Trump campaign
had foreknowledge of when they were
going to be released as well so without
getting into the really technical stuff
that's not really of interest to our
audience and not really relevant to most
of our audience what happened is that
gusoff er slipped up Lucifer at 2.0 was
portraying themselves as Romanian that
was sort of suspect all along because of
the really terrible Romanian that goose'
42.0 appeared to speak and long story
short US investigators have identified
gusoff for 2.0 not generally as a
Russian intelligence officer but as a
specific GRU office
sir working out of the GRU headquarters
in a particular office in Moscow Russia
and this happened because normally
goose' 42.0 would use a VPN that's a
Virtual Private Network and that hides
their actual location one time at least
one time that we know about gusoff er
did not activate that VPN and left an
actual real Moscow IP address in the
server logs of an American social media
company gusoff er 2.0 we know was
directly in touch with Crump Advisor
Roger stone via Twitter Stone has
admitted this but the big news here is
that this makes it even more difficult
for Donald Trump to deny collusion and
coordination it makes it even more
difficult to believe that Trump and his
associates were not directly involved
with someone who we now know to be a
Russian intelligence officer because for
a long time you had Trump in his
administration denying what was the
intelligence community consensus that
Russia was behind the dnc hacks we also
know from the public timing of a number
of different social media posts and
meetings and public statements that
there seemed to be some pretty
significant awareness even maybe ahead
of time of when these leaks were going
to take place if the hackers who got
those documents are Russian intelligence
officers that is yet another link
between Donald Trump and his team's
knowledge of these hacks and the Russian
individual who did the hacking but even
putting Trump aside for a second here
Roger stone admitted that he was in
touch with someone who we now know to
have been a Russian intelligence officer
lucifer 2.0 who did the hacking that's
sort of like a case closed
end of story and i can only imagine that
this isn't going to go unnoticed by
robert muller and and by the way we've
also learned that robert muller has now
taken over the investigation of goose'
42.0 which puts yet another layer onto
this Moeller can now prove that Roger
stone who was one of Trump's closest
advisors was in touch not just generally
with the vague and amorphous
Russians stone was in touch with a
specific nameable intelligence operative
in Russia I just hope that before we
find out more about this we don't hear
that this intelligence officer has
accidentally fallen on a knife ten times
and then subsequently thrown himself out
of a window these accidents happen all
the time in Russia accidentally
ingesting polonium happens all the time
to people that could be a liability to
the Russian state I really hope that
that doesn't happen here because this is
actually a major story sometimes people
will shoot themselves in the head four
or five times because I didn't even know
you could do I didn't have that either
yeah or or in the back multiple times
it's crazy what people are able to do in
Russia when they just coincidentally
happen to be in a situation that is
dangerous when it comes to the Kremlin's
perspective this also by the way starts
to paint a more accurate picture of why
sam nunn burg seemed just horrified
about the possibility of turning over
his communications with Roger stone to
robert muller how many weeks ago was it
that the number it was like two three
weeks ago yeah sam nunn Berg went on all
sorts of media and and started saying
he's ignoring a subpoena from Robert
Muller that he's not going to turn over
his communications with Roger stone and
he seemed a combination of both under
the influence of alcohol which Erin
Burnett pointed out during her CNN
interview and just genuinely afraid and
now that we know that stone was not only
in touch generally with Russians but
with goose' 42.0 who we now know to be a
Russian intelligence officer I actually
get why nunberg was so afraid right if I
was nunberg and I knew what stone was
doing and maybe speculated or had an
inkling that gusoff er was a Russian
intelligence operative and Moeller says
give me all your communications that
you've had with Roger stone I'd probably
look as afraid as nunberg myself and
would be drinking before national TV
interview oh sure and Sam Nunn Berg said
that he didn't want to betray Roger
stone because he was his longtime
longtime mentor right I mean you gotta
have a better reason than that you're
gonna flip pretty quickly I think if
you're up against Robert Muller I think
that we have seen those who we would
have presumed loyalty to the Trump
apparatus from
already and it never rang true from the
beginning and now we're learning more
about why so it's gonna be an
interesting several weeks that's for
sure let's take a break discuss this and
any other stories from today's show on
the David Pakman show
subreddit which you can subscribe to
instantly at david pakman.com slash our
EDD i.t The Daily Beast has just a
blockbuster article out which if it's
accurate confirms what would be really
the first publicly known connection
between Trump staffers and associates
and not just Russians but Russian
intelligence operatives known
colloquially sometimes as Russian spies
and we're talking here about Rick gates
Rick Gates is the business partner a
former Trump campaign chairman Paul
Manafort both of whom have been indicted
by special prosecutor Robert Muller and
what The Daily Beast has learned and is
reporting is that the prosecutors
working for Robert Muller have now been
able to directly link gates to a person
tied to Russian intelligence obvious
question we should all have when the
Daily Beast reports this how do we learn
how did they learn this and the way that
they learned this is because of court
filings that were released a couple of
days ago which say that gates and an
unnamed person who worked for one of
Paul mana forts companies were in touch
in the months leading up to the November
of 2016 election I think they
specifically know even September and
October August September October
somewhere in that range and they've
described the connections between gates
and this individual linked to Russian
intelligence as quote pertinent to the
investigation meaning Robert molars
investigation into Trump Russia
coordination collusion and possible
criminality the court filing the same
court filing that's the basis of this
daily beast report also says and this is
the key part right that Gates knew that
this individual was connected to Russian
intelligence and if true absolutely huge
absolutely huge because this is crossing
the line into knowing and deliberate
contact specifically
for the purposes of the Donald Trump
campaign with individuals in the Russian
government in this case it's even more
specific specific in the sense that it's
Russian intelligence operatives now
there are people who will hear me say
this and I'll get call the calls from
them emails live calls who knows maybe
tomorrow we'll hear from some of them
who will say David
there is simply no evidence that a crime
took place no matter what coordination
there was no matter what quote collusion
there was but that now is also a
narrative that we have to refute because
the list of possible crimes here
continues to get longer and longer the
more we learn about what took place so
accepting assistance and things of value
be they money or information as we've
talked about from foreign entities for a
federal election in the United States is
a crime right that's one possible crime
that is on the list here covering up
those incidents of receiving things of
value also a crime obstructing
investigations into those incidents
regarding the receipt of things of value
from foreign entities for elections is
also a crime lying to investigators
about those incidents is a crime and
when multiple people work together to
either cover up or obstruct or mislead
that can also be the crime of conspiracy
and the talking point from the Russia
denialists and there's some on the right
and there's some on the left as you
probably well know at this point is
David collusions not a crime collusion
simply is not something that is a crime
in the criminal code that's sort of like
saying killing people with guns isn't a
crime I can find no crime called or
described as killing people with guns
well just because it's not in the
Criminal Code that way doesn't mean it
isn't this thing called murder right and
that starts to become really a semantic
disagreement colluding where the foreign
entity provides things of material value
is a crime it wouldn't be called the
collusion but we're speaking
colloquially here about the various cry
that might be included under that
umbrella now also stunning is that this
story barely registered yesterday in the
midst of news about Trump bragging about
what's going on with North Korea stormy
Daniels Trump missing from the public
eye with absolutely nothing scheduled up
until today for long periods of time
Facebook story and even if this story
did get more coverage the committed
trumpets aren't going to care right
they'll talk about what what's going on
with Donald Trump and unemployment or
whatever the same unemployment numbers
that they didn't believe under President
Obama and in fact I saw the other day on
CNN the day that CNN reared Anderson
Cooper's 60 minutes interview with
stormy Daniels CNN sat down with a bunch
of Trump voting women I don't remember
where it was I think it was somewhere in
the south and it was just total
cognitive dissonance right some of them
saying this was a long time ago others
saying we simply don't believe it others
saying Trump's personal life all of a
sudden just isn't a concern for us
because his legislative positions are
Christian and close to God so if you're
waiting around as I know there are some
people waiting around they email me they
say David as soon as X happens then the
trumpets will fully abandon Trump no
they won't the trumpets are
ideologically and fully committed to
Donald Trump and the extent to which
cognitive dissonance is going to keep
them there goes well beyond another
dozen accusers of sexual assault against
Donald Trump or even more connections
here with Russia so we've got to just
forget about them and we've got to do
whatever we can to make sure that
justice is carried out here because
they're not going to come over to the
side of logic and reason things have not
been going well for right-wing news
website Breitbart of a trump advisor
Steve ban and fame there Avenue the era
their ad revenue has been falling off a
cliff more and more companies have been
pulling ad from the website there's been
a really great social media shame
campaign to get advertisers to pull
money from Breitbart
and there's now a new allegation against
Breitbart and it relates to the failed
candidacy of serial accused child sex
assault or Roy Moore in Alabama special
election a lawyer representing one of
Moore's accusers has come
forward and said that some of Roy Moore
supporters offered him money to drop the
accuser as a client now how does it
involve Breitbart part of the offer was
that the lawyer would make a specific
statement about dropping the accuser as
a client which would be released only
and directly to Breitbart news he would
also be paid ten thousand dollars and
get the pleasure I guess of being
introduced directly to Stephen Bennett
so this has immediately raised questions
about why did he have to go to Breitbart
with a statement as part of the
agreement why would anyone even think to
include that was anyone involved in
trying to pay off the attorney to drop
his client working with or connected to
Breitbart at Breitbart in the first
place and the bigger question is is the
allegation credible and I don't really
have trouble believing that Breitbart
and more supporters would try to hurt
the accusers by getting that rid of
their legal representation the only part
that strikes me as less believable is
that they think they could buy the
lawyer with just ten thousand bucks
right you would imagine that
professional bribers know you've got to
offer more than ten grand to a lawyer to
get them to drop such a notable client
who's in the public eye and for what
it's worth the people named in the
article is being involved in reaching
out to the lawyer haven't deny doing
this they've simply said we did not do
anything wrong or illegal which is
basically like saying yeah we did it and
it was perfectly fine to do and the the
projection here is just stunning because
you'll remember that when the Washington
Post first broke some of the stories of
these accusers of Roy Moore you had
people on the right who were saying the
Washington Post paid the women to make
up the stories now we look of course
there was no evidence of that
now we learn that it actually might have
been the right trying to pay off the
lawyers representing the accusers so
that they would drop the cases and it is
absolutely pathetic and disgusting if
true the the there's a very clear silver
lining here though which is that
Breitbart really seems to be in dis
Raye and on its way down that is a
really great media story it remains to
be seen if they ultimately meet their
total demise but the latest allegations
that they were directly involved in this
truly and absolutely disgusting and will
continue to follow what ultimately
happens with Breitbart yesterday I was
checking out Donald Trump's Twitter
account as I often do and there was
plenty of sort of weird grammar and
random capitalization very very childish
language syntax and in the midst of all
that I saw Trump tweeting pictures of a
wall and some construction equipment
saying we're starting the Mexico wall
construction and I found it sort of
weird because they're only now working
on getting some of the initial money to
start some border wall construction so I
thought how could it be that they're
already starting construction like it
can take days just to even get the
equipment to where it needs to be so
today I looked into it in more detail
and it turns out that Trump actually
tweeted pictures of previously planned
repairs to existing areas of border
fencing that have actually been there
since the 1990s and Donald Trump's
pictures are completely misleading
fabrications but I'm sure that they're
playing really really well with his base
Trump tweeted yesterday great briefing
this afternoon on the start of our
southern border wall and if you look at
the pictures a number of them there
you'll see pictures of what genuinely
appears to be construction of some kind
of wall or fence but it turns out that
this project Trump is tweeting about
started almost 10 years ago it has
nothing to do with Trump whatsoever and
in fact some of the exact same pictures
that Trump included in his tweet were
tweeted weeks ago by border patrol in a
post about the replacement of a section
of a couple of miles of fence that was
already predetermined that it would take
place and what's more there hasn't even
been a decision made yet as to what the
new wall will look like as well as if
and when construction will start which
it has
yet it's another day and it's another
lie and the theme that we're seeing is
the belligerence of the lies going up
right whole cloth concocted lies
yesterday sarah huckabee sanders on the
census on census questions on the i'm
sorry
citizenship questions on the census
issue saying over the other than 2010
we've had a question about citizenship
on every census since 1965 whole cloth
fabrications Trump just tweeting
pictures of something that's completely
unrelated to his Mexico border wall and
I think that this is a good opportunity
to take this even further the new
conversation about the wall is how much
money will be made available for it will
the military pay for it right that's a
new idea that Donald Trump has come up
with when will we be able to start
construction on it this is providing
cover for the premise and promise that's
been long forgotten that Mexico was
going to pay for the wall right Donald
Trump throughout the campaign said
Mexico is gonna pay for the wall that I
promised you who's even talking about
that anymore nobody because it was alive
from the beginning it was never going to
happen and it's the last thing that
right-wingers want to talk about and if
you force them to talk about it they'll
say well it's the fault of Democrats or
Mexicans or whoever that it's not going
to happen if it were up to trump it
would but that's the whole point a lot
of things that if they were up to the
candidate would happen if it were up to
Bernie we'd have Medicare for all that
doesn't mean that just promising it with
no plan is something we should excuse
because if it were unilaterally up to
them it would happen and I was thinking
about this and I wondered is it possible
that someone maybe to keep Trump from
becoming irate we know he gets it twice
a day
propaganda good news file is it possible
someone came to trump with these
pictures and said look mr. Trump they're
building the wall and Trump has been
tricked into thinking that this is the
wall I don't know I saw an interesting
analogy on Reddit a lot of us growing up
if you had Nintendo your little brother
or sister wanted to play and maybe it
wasn't a two-player game or you didn't
want to be bothered so you would hand
them a controller that wasn't plugged
into anything
and they would just be happy because
they thought that they were playing is
the equivalent being done with Trump
where he was given pictures of this
border fence and he genuinely thinks
they're doing the thing he well I don't
know I think he was actively trying to
deceive his base you just and that's
because he has to fulfill that campaign
promise when it comes to some of the
other ones like the economy is going to
soar or we're gonna win so much you're
gonna be tired of winning with that
stuff you can kind of like cherry-pick
information when it comes to the wall
when in 2020 comes around it's gonna be
is there a wall constructed on the
southern border or is there not well and
it's very clear what they're going to
say which is they'll use stuff like
what's happening the replacement of
fencing from 1990's that has been
scheduled to be replaced for almost ten
years they'll say that's an example of
Trump achieving it if he's not able to
achieve more lie after lie after lie